firmer valdez is looking to have a good
start
right here at minute maid park we talked
about the last couple inflating that era
to 4.08
last time out he pitched against the
dodgers only went five innings gave up
five earned runs on two home runs but
had seven strikeouts but i think that
was a little bit of a residual effect
from that outing he had in anaheim where
he pitched
seven strong innings gave up a bunch of
runs but he did it in 110 degree heat
kind of fulfill on deck and then sola
they play leotie pretty much straight up
there's a right-handed hitter
and the pitch is chopped off the plate
out towards second backhanded by
altuve and as he goes to transfer he
drops the ball
and tavares reaches safely tavares of
course has great speed that was not
going to be an easy play for jose altuve
so the rangers have two on with one out
for joey gallo
swing and a miss another strikeout for
from valdez so a couple of infield hits
and a couple of strikeouts that's how
this game starts two away
2-2 pitch and odor goes down fromer
strikes out three in the first
and works around a couple of infield
hits jordan horton
lyles getting ready to deal him into his
former club he played for the astros
from 2011 to 2013.
here's the pitch that's hit high on the
air down the right field line joey gallo
cruising in and toward the line makes a
one-handed grab and
there is one away there's michael
bratley
brantley swings roles went out to odor
in short right he flings it to first in
the dirt but it's dug out by apostle
and it is a one two three inning for
lyles so bregman's on he's the first
astros base runner
no score here bottom of the second and
kyle tucker coming up next
3-2 pitch hit high in the air pretty
deep sending joey gala all the way back
to the wall this ball's gone
kyle tucker with a home run his ninth of
the year giving the astros a two to
nothing lead
not crushed but good enough tried to
beat him up and in
he opened up got the barrel to it and
lofted it out to right field and joey
gallo just drifting
drifting drifting and just not enough
room for him
here's michael brantley apparently
grounded out his first time up
2-2 here his shot out into center field
a base knock for michael brantley
so bradley one for two that's the third
houston hit and it brings up alex
bregman
the one two is chopped toward third
charged by keiner falefa his throw from
near the mound is in time
to get pregnant nice play by isaiah
keiner falefa
who continues to impress at third bait
two out
of the runner second and that'll leave
it up to yet another young man another
22
year old in anderson to haita the switch
hitter valdez set
takes a deep breath let kick the pitch
strike three called that one on the
outside corner with the hook
tucker with the two-run homer back in
the second inning that's the game's only
run
so far the 3-2 pitch fastball
at the knees for a call third strike
nice looking pitch there from jordan
lyles
here's correa the 1-2 hit past lyles but
roogie to his right on the outfield
grass has it on the backhand side low
throw
but scooped out by apostle as lyles
retires the side in order
proper through four innings has 71
pitches on his total which is a little
high
the 1-2 to eli white did he go around he
sure did couldn't hold up on the hook
and that's the seventh strikeout for
fromber one away
when he gets ahead of the count he can
drop that hook on you and keep it low
it's over now it's jeff mathis a
strikeout victim his first time
up the one-two swing and a miss got him
on a curve ball
here's leodi tavares an infield hit and
a ground out there's a call
third strike from her valdez strikes out
the side
first up josh reddick in the bottom of
the fifth on the other hit or correa
single
here's a swing and a high pop up to
short center tavares with this sliding
ground
for farmer valdez six shutout innings so
far
three hits that's it here's roonetto
door
and he tried to hold up that one's in
the dirt as maldonado makes the play
that is 11 strikeouts for fraumer valdez
matching his career high
apostle 0 for two he is grounded to
first he has also bounced out the short
here's a swing and a line drive into
right field and this one sits and gets
past reddick and goes all the way to the
wall
apostle around first on his way to
second and he's in there with a stand-up
double so his second big league hit
and he gives the rangers an opportunity
here in the seventh down by two
baker will take him out as valdez with
another
great game six and a third so far
shutout baseball leads two to nothing as
he walks back to the dugout
so the outros go to the bullpen josh
james will be the new pitcher for the
astros
two gone here at the top of the seventh
and it brings eli white to the plate
the 3-1 is lined into left center of
base hit for eli white
rounding third is shirt and apostle he
comes in to score standing up as the
throw goes back into the infield
so a two out run scoring single for eli
white puts the rangers on the board here
at two to one
that's two quick outs for brooks raleigh
and that pastel will come to the plate
here
this ball to alex bregman one big hop
brooks rayleigh picks up his first major
league save and the astros take the
series
with a 2-1 victory over the texas
rangers